FOUND AND WE HAVE A THEN AND NOW
TAPE OF NANCY PELOSI THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO HIT YOUR DVR ON.
LET’S GET RIGHT TO OUR TOP
STORY, LIEUTENANT GENERAL
MICHAEL FLYNN IS AND HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AN INNOCENT MAN AND THAT’S
MORE CLEAR THAN EVER THAT A FEW
CORRUPT HIGH-RANKING DEEP STATE
BUREAUCRATS SET HIM UP, THEY
WERE ALL BRAGGING ABOUT IT AND
ALL SIGNS POINT TO THE CORRUPT
LEADERSHIP OF A HIGHER CALLING
HONOR, MISTER SUPER PATRIOT
JIM COMEY.
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO NEWLY
UNREDACTED FBI DOCUMENTS JUST
RELEASED TODAY, IN EARLY JANUARY
DETERMINED FLYNN WAS NO LONGER A
VIABLE CANDIDATE AS PART OF
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, HE DID
NOTHING WRONG.
THESE DOCUMENTS REPORT THERE WAS
NO DEROGATORY MATERIAL ON FLYNN
IN THE FBI FILES, NO DEROGATORY
MATERIAL IN THE DEFENSE INTEL
AGENCY FILES.
NO DEROGATORY MATERIAL IN THE
CIA FILES AND BY JANUARY 4TH,
THE CASE AGAINST FLYNN, THEY
SAID IT WAS GOING TO BE DROPPED,
THAT IS UNTIL THE CORRUPT UPPER
ECHELON OF THE FBI ALREADY
INVOLVED IN CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE JUMPED IN.
PETER STRZOK SENT SEVERAL URGENT
TEXTS DEMANDING TO KNOW IF THE
CASE IS STILL OPEN, TO HIS
RELIEF THE CASE WAS NEVER
OFFICIALLY CLOSED.
HE TEXTED OKAY, IT’S STILL OPEN,
OUR UTTER INCOMPETENCE ACTUALLY
HELPS US.
THAT’S BREATHTAKING.
HE INFORMED HIS COLLEAGUES AT
THE SEVENTH FLOOR -- WHAT’S THE
SEVENTH FLOOR?
THAT’S WHERE THE FBI UPPER
ECHELON LEADERSHIP IS, A FEW
CORRUPT AGENTS DID IN FACT
CONSPIRE, THEY SET FLYNN UP ALL
UNDER THE WATCH OF JAMES COMEY.
ON JANUARY 24TH 2017, 1 AGENT
ASKED "WHAT IS OUR GOAL?
IS A TRUTH OR IS OUR GOAL TO GET
HIM TO LIVE SO THEN WE CAN
PROSECUTE HIM OR GET HIM FIRED?"
THAT IS NOT A QUESTION THAT
SHOULD EVER BE ASKED BY ANYONE,
ANY PROFESSIONAL AND WOULD NEVER
BE ASKED BY THE 99% OF BRAVE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FBI.
SHOULD IT ALWAYS BE TRUTH, THE
RULE OF LAW THEY WORK IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF JUSTICE,
ACCORDING TO AMERICA’S NUMBER
ONE SUPER PATRIOT, SETTING A
PERJURY TRAP, A CONTEXT FOR AN
AMERICAN WAR HERO, 33 YEARS OF
SERVICE UNDER HIS BELT FOR THIS
COUNTRY SO WE CAN ALL LIVE FREE.
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
ONE UNREDACTED NOTE, AGENTS
CONSIDERED USING THE LOGAN ACT
AS THE CENTERPIECE OF THEIR
SKIN, NOBODY HAS EVER BEEN FOUND
GUILTY OF VIOLATING THIS ARCANE
LAW SINCE IT WAS PASSED IN 1799.
THE LOGAN ACT HAS BEEN USED
REPEATEDLY AS A PARTISAN TOOL TO
HARASS POLITICAL OPPONENTS FOR
MORE THAN TWO CENTURIES AND WHAT
EXACTLY HAPPENED?
JANUARY 24TH, 4 DAYS AFTER
DONALD TRUMP WAS INAUGURATED,
MR. HIGHER LOYALTY SUPER PATRIOT
JIM COMEY DIRECTED AGENTS TO GO
IN AND AMBUSH A 33 YEAR WAR VET
AT THE WHITE HOUSE JUST FOUR
DAYS AFTER TRUMP’S INAUGURATION
AND AFTER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
McCABE OF THE FBI SAID YOU
DON’T NEED A LAWYER, THIS ISN’T
ABOUT YOU, NOT AT ALL.
SINCE THE WHITE HOUSE WAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF CHAOS, IT’S ALWAYS
CHAOS DURING A TRANSITION --
COMEY SAW A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY
TO LAY HIS TRAP.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO TAKE MY WORD
FOR IT, WE GOT JAMES COMEY ON
TAPE KIND OF LIKE QUID PRO QUO
JOE, WRITING ABOUT SETUPS HE
WOULD NEVER GET AWAY WITH IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE HE
DECIDED NOT TO USE -- TAKE A
LOOK.
>> YOU LOOK AT THIS WHITE HOUSE
NOW AND IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE TWO
FBI AGENTS COMING UP -- HOW DOES
THAT ADD UP?
>> I SENT THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN’T
HAVE DONE OR MAY BE GOTTEN AWAY
WITH IN A MORE ORGANIZED
INVESTIGATION, MORE ORGANIZED
ADMINISTRATION, IN THE
GEORGE W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION
FOR EXAMPLE AND IN BOTH OF THOSE
ADMINISTRATIONS THERE WAS
PROCESS.
IF THE FBI WANTED TO SEND AGENTS
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE ITSELF TO
INTERVIEW A SENIOR OFFICIAL, YOU
WOULD WORK THROUGH THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL AND THERE
WOULD BE DISCUSSIONS AND
APPROVALS AND I THOUGHT IT’S
EARLY ENOUGH, LET’S JUST SEND A
COUPLE GUYS OVER.
>> Sean: I SENT THEM, I SENT A
COUPLE OF GUYS UP THERE,
SOMETHING I WOULD NEVER DO OR
GET AWAY WITH IN THE BUSH OR
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION’S, I SENT
THEM.
WOW.
A FOLLOWING COMEY’S AMBUSH, THE
INVESTIGATORS CANNOT BELIEVE
THAT FLYNN WAS LYING, HOW DO YOU
LIKE THAT?
AFTER MULTIPLE MAJOR REVISIONS
OF INTERROGATION AND NOTES BY
PETER STRZOK, LISA PAGE, THE FBI
WAS ABLE TO CHARGE FLYNN WITH A
CRIME THAT HE DIDN’T COMMIT AND
THEY THREATENED HIS SON, WANT TO
KNOW HOW GOOD A FATHER THAT
LIEUTENANTLIEUTENANT GENERAL FLY
HE DECIDED YOU’RE GOING TO TURN
ON MY SON?
I HAVE TO PHONE THE SWORD FOR MY
SON.
IF NOT BEFORE THEY TURN THE
SCREWS, THEY THREATENED TO THROW
HIM BEHIND BARS, THREATENED HIS
SON AND HIS FAMILY, HE HAD
MOUNTING LEGAL BILLS, HE’S BROKE
AFTER 33 YEARS OF SERVICE.
HE WAS BANKRUPT, LOST HIS HOUSE,
REPUTATION AND RUINS ALL BECAUSE
OF COMEY, HIS CORRUPT AGENTS AT
THE TOP OF THE FBI, THEY ALL
HATED TRUMP, THEY’VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN STOPPING HIM GETTING
ELECTED AND SABOTAGING HIM EVER
SINCE, SPYING ON HIM IN THE
WORDS OF ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
DEEP INTO THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS WHY YOU MAKE A
DISTINCTION.
THIS FBI PIN IS IN SOLIDARITY
FOR THE 99% OF THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS,
THEY SERVICE BRAVELY AND WITH
HONOR AND INTEGRITY, THE BEST OF
THE BEST.
BUT THE MALIGNANT, AGENDA DRIVEN
1% ARE NOW THREATENING THE VERY
BASIS OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM,
THEY MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND TO THE CREDIT OF THIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE IS DOING
JUST THAT.
HE IS FOLLOWING JUSTICE AND THE
RULE OF LAW, EQUAL APPLICATION
OF THE LAW, EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW.
THEY RUINED THE LIFE OF AN
AMERICAN WAR HERO, THEY SPIED ON
CARTER PAGE AND RUINED HIS LIFE.
THEY USED A PHIS APPLICATION, A
WARRANT WITH HILLARY CLINTON’S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY
DOSSIER FULL OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION THAT RUSSIA, EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" GETS THIS
CLEARLY USED TO HELP CLINTON AND
MESS WITH OUR ELECTIONS.
THE RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION THAT
HILLARY IS PAYING FOR, IT’S
UNVERIFIABLE BECAUSE IT’S
DEBUNKED.
DEVIN NUNES WARNED OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY IN 2014 THAT THE HOSTILE
REGIME IN RUSSIA AND A HOSTILE
ACT OF PUTIN WOULD DO THIS.
THE THEY DID NOTHING TO STOP IT,
THEY SPIED ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, THE TRUMP TRANSITION
TEAM AND EVEN THE AG POINTED OUT
DEEP INTO THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THEY LAID A PERJURY TRAP IN THIS
CASE, THEY SET A PERJURY TRAP
FOR GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, THEY
KNOCKED DOWN PAUL MANAFORT’S
DOOR, THEY’D RAIDED HIS HOME IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT GUNS
DRAWN FOR TAX FRAUD CHARGES AND
THEY SENT DOZENS OF AGENTS, 30
OF THEM, TACTICAL GEAR TO
SURROUND THE HOME OF ROGER STONE
AT 3:00 A.M. FOR A PROCESS CRIME
OR THAT THE INSPECTOR SUSPECTS
THAT COMEY AND McCABE
THEMSELVES ARE GUILTY OF.
THEY RAIDED THE HOUSE 3:00 A.M.,
ROGER STONE INVITED CNN TO FILM
AT ALL, HE HAPPENED TO BE IN THE
RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THEY ALLEGEDLY LIED TO CONGRESS.
USUALLY WHAT THEY SAY IS CAN YOU
REPORT AT 8:00 A.M., THAT WOULD
BE THE WAY YOU HANDLE THAT.
IF WHAT IS THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR IN ALL THIS?
IT’S PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO TAKE DOWN THE
ADMINISTRATION, THIS PRESIDENT
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT HAD THIS TO
SAY ABOUT THE CORRUPT AGENTS IN
THE DEEP STATE AND THEIR
CHEERLEADERS IN THE MOB WHICH IS
99% OF THE MEDIA TODAY, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> CNN TORMENTED HIM IN ALL
FAIRNESS, I REALLY HOPE TO SEE
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN’T BEEN DOING
IT AND I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION.
I HOPE TO SEE THAT CNN -- WILL
NOT EVEN APOLOGIZE, WHICH THEY
SHOULD BUT JUST COVER IT FAIRLY
BECAUSE HE’S IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING EXONERATED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE NOTES FROM
YESTERDAY, THAT WAS TOTAL
EXONERATION.
THESE WERE DIRTY, FILTHY COPS AT
THE TOP OF THE FBI.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN RIGHT, WE’VE BEEN RIGHT, WE
REPORTED THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS
ABUSE OF POWER AND CORRUPTION
AND FOR THREE PLUS YEARS IT’S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A LONELY
ROAD.
ALL MEDIA OUTLETS INCLUDING
SOCIALIST STATE TV,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," INSTEAD OF
HOLDING OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE, THEY WERE CHEERING
FOR THE DEMISE OF A AMERICAN WAR
HERO AND WANTED TO TAKE OUT DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
>> DID FLYNN GO ROGUE WHEN HE
SPOKE TO RUSSIA?
>> THAT WOULD BE A BIGGER
SCANDAL THAN ALMOST ANYTHING
WE’VE EVER SEEN IN ANY
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE’RE GOING TO GET BACK TO
MICHAEL FLYNN’S GUILTY PLEA,
IT’S A HISTORIC DAY IN D.C.
>> THE FACT IS MICHAEL FLYNN
BETRAYED HIS COUNTRY.
>> THE WARRANT APPLICATION WAS
BASED ON PROBABLE CAUSE, NOT
PROOF THAT HE WAS A FOREIGN
AGENT.
>> A JUDGE ALL BUT CALLED HIM A
TRAITOR, THE PRESIDENT WISHED
HIM WELL.
>> AFTER TWO HOURS OF A JUDGE
REBUKING MICHAEL FLYNN USING
WORDS SUCH AS TREASON,
DISCUSSED, AND DISDAIN.
>> Sean: YOU THINK ANY OF
THESE OUTLETS HAVE THE HONOR,
DECENCY, CONCERN FOR TRUTH AND
JUSTICE AND INTEGRITY TO SAY TO
GENERAL FLYNN, WE’RE SORRY?
DON’T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
BUREAUCRATS, TREMENDOUS POWER.
THE MOB, TREMENDOUS POWER.
RUINING THE LIVES OF INNOCENT
AMERICANS, TRYING TO INFLUENCE
AN ELECTION, TRYING TO UNSEAT A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT, WALMART
SHOPPER, GUNS, BIBLE, BELIEVE IN
GOD THE PEOPLE.
THE MOB, THEY HELP THEM EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
JOURNALISM IS DEAD, I’VE TOLD
YOU, IT’S DEAD BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DEMAND JUSTICE, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO GO OUR OWN WAY
COME UP FORGE OUR OWN PATH ON
THIS SHOW, WE HAVE BEEN
UNRELENTING FOR THREE YEARS AND
WE ARE NOT STOPPING.
JUSTICE, FAIRNESS, FREEDOM, THE
FABRIC OF OUR REPUBLIC NEED
SOMETHING TO US AND THANKS TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, KUDOS TO
BILL BARR.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HIS JOB.
THAT’S WHAT HIS JOB IS, FOLLOW
THE LAW.